c'était un immense village de petites
habitations en bois près du centre-ville
de marche à rebours c'est aujourd'hui un
entrelacs de débris de containers et de
végétation brassée par l'ouragan
le quartier s'appelait mode et il faut
marcher sur les maisons pour enfin
accéder aux survivants le fonctionnaire
oui regardez depuis dimanche on essaye
de faire sécher nos affaires un quartier
pauvre d'haïtiens qui tente d'organiser
leur survie on n'a pas encore trouvé
lundi madness ne sait pas dire combien
de gens sont morts ici je deux poulains
qui ont disparu et en disparu aucune
équipe de secours n'est encore arrivé
jusqu'à mode ces haïtiens ne savent
absolument pas où aller ils errent dans
les rues de marche à rebours désespéré
et voudrait être évacués
pour quitter l'île la seule solution ce
sont les avions ou les hélicoptères sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport qui a enfin
séché de petits jets
cette famille a fait venir un avion
privé des états unis je suis tellement
heureuse de partir si vous voyez notre
ville il ya plus rien à des entreprises
envoient aussi leurs appareils récupérer
leurs salariés mais pour les autres
c'est la tente
la piste reste silencieuse de longs
moments à la porte de l'aéroport ils
sont nombreux on est venu à l'aube pour
prendre le premier vol du gouvernement
il avait dix premiers arrivés premiers
servis mais c'est pas comme ça ce seront
d'abord les malades les femmes et les
enfants qui partiront laissant derrière
eux marchent à rebours et ses ruines de
la praye déluge